[Music]
on this Friday night another case of
police brutality in the U.S no mother
should go through what I'm going through
right now body cam video of the violent
arrest of Tyree Nichols is called
appalling he was
a human pinata the five officers charged
with murder and fears the case will
spark protests graphic video of Paul
Pelosi's attack drop the hammer the
police body cam footage released
and a deadly shooting at a synagogue in
Jerusalem what's being done to stop the
sickening rise of anti-Semitism people
saying that they want to gasp me and my
entire family
[Music]
Rebel National with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin tonight with video of another Act
of police brutality in the U.S five
officers in Memphis Tennessee have been
fired they've been charged with
second-degree murder in the death of 29
year old Tyree Nichols police body cam
footage of what happened has been
released it shows him being pulled over
for a traffic stop officers drag him out
of his car he does not appear to be
resisting and says he's just trying to
get home then police deploy a taser and
pepper spray he runs away is apprehended
again brutally beaten and then left
lying injured without medical care
his last words on this Earth
is Mom
mom
but for me to find out that my son was
calling my name and I was only your
feets away it would did not even hear
him
you have no clue how I feel right now
no clue
that is Tyree Nichols mother even in her
grief she is calling for calm there's
concern this police video might reignite
simmering anger about police brutality
Eric Sorensen has our top story tonight
in a warning the video is graphic and
difficult to watch
[Music]
a grief-stricken memorial for another
young black man in America who died
after being arrested by police in
Memphis 29-year-old Tyree Nichols was
pulled over in his car January 7th the
confrontation left Nichols badly beaten
in hospital he died three days later
five Memphis police officers all black
have now been charged with second-degree
murder and other charges Memphis Police
have now released video of the
confrontation
do anything body cam images show police
arresting nickels police told him to lie
down he said he was on the ground
Nichols breaks free and began running
police gave Chase
they caught him and police began
striking him Nichols told him he's just
trying to go home which was not far away
he called for his mother repeatedly some
of the pictures and were not showing
them only get far worse as police hit
him and hit him repeatedly as the family
lawyer described it the young man was
defenseless
unabashed
non-stop beating of this young boy for
three minutes oh my God
rovonne Wells said later she couldn't
bear to watch it through once I heard my
son say what did I do
I just I lost it it is unbearable for a
mother do you know how I feel right now
because I wasn't there for my son
Nichol's death another case of a young
black man dying from the actions of
police is a symptom of what experts call
systemic racism regardless of whether
the officers or black officers or white
officers I think that's a very
simplistic understanding and there's a
much more profound problem about the
nature of policing itself that I think
we need to think about the family's
lawyer says in this case a group of
black police officers was arrested and
charged quickly and that all police
should face similar accountability from
now on this is the blueprint going
forward
for any time any officers whether they
be black or white
will be held accountable other cases of
police brutality caught on camera have
led to Violent protests from Rodney King
in Los Angeles 30 years ago to George
Floyd in Minneapolis in 2020 and that is
the fear once more Tyree Nichols
stepfather is asking the public not to
turn violent when they see the
disturbing video we do not want any type
of uproar we do not want any type of
disturbance we want peaceful protests
Nichols family says nothing can bring
back their son but they are satisfied
with the charges that have been laid
this just shouldn't have happened
and
we want Justice for my son Eric Sorensen
Global News
another police video was released today
the attack on Paul Pelosi the husband of
Nancy Pelosi former speaker of the U.S
House of Representatives that attack
happened at their San Francisco home
Nancy Pelosi who was the target was not
home at the time a judge has now ruled
there was no reason to keep the video
secret it starts when police who had
responded to a call get to the front
door we're not going to show you the
moment Pelosi was attacked with a hammer
but a warning some may still find the
footage disturbing
how you doing oh yeah what's going on
man everything's good
hi drop the hammer
um nope hey hey hey hey what is going on
right now
that body cam footage was released
alongside security Vision video showing
the alleged attacker David smashing a
window in order to break into the house
as well as a 9-1-1 call of Paul Pelosi
speaking to a dispatcher apparently with
depap right next to him Paul Pelosi did
survive that attack but he suffered a
fractured skull and is still recovering
there's been a serious escalation in
violence between Israelis and
Palestinians a Palestinian gunman killed
at least seven people outside of
synagogue in East Jerusalem a day after
Israeli forces killed nine Palestinians
in a raid on the West Bank City of
Janine
at least three other Israelis were
injured in the shooting after prayers at
a synagogue Israeli authorities are
calling it a terror attack the suspect
was killed by the police it happened on
Holocaust Memorial Day and during
Shabbat the Jewish day of rest the
renewal of such violence is worrying at
least 30 Palestinians have been killed
by Israeli Defense Forces this month and
Palestinian militants had warned they
would respond
this is the day people around the world
pause to remember what happened during
the Holocaust The Six Million Jewish
people and others persecuted and
murdered by the Nazis during the second
world war anti-Semitism is on the rise
around the world in all levels of
society tonight Karen Lieberman looks at
how people are being empowered to combat
the hate
I could say anti-semitic things and
Adidas can't drop me from high profile
entertainers online and in real life
anti-Semitism is being expressed
publicly and violently
when somebody like a Kanye comes out and
makes anti-semitic statements
young people that idolize this
individual don't think that they think
well there's something to it in Ottawa
High School students charged with hate
crime offenses my son and a friend of
his two Jewish students were were
brought into the shower locker room on
the floor of that locker room a swastika
that was made out of ski poles
Dr Neely kaplan-merth a school board
trustee and family doctor has herself
been the target of hate people saying
that they want to gas me and my entire
family that they want my children to
burn to die to be tortured statistics
Canada finds Jewish Canadians
representing around one percent of the
population Remain the most targeted for
hate crimes in this country and then in
2016 after Donald Trump was elected and
gave license to bigots and anti-semites
to come out of the woodwork you saw all
over social media an incredible
escalation of anti-Semitism as the
Jewish community of Squirrel Hill
prepares to bury its dead in Pittsburgh
October 2018 11 Jewish people were
killed in a synagogue while attending
Saturday morning services in the wake of
recent Horrors Holocaust Survivor Rose
lipstick hopes sharing her story helps
curb the rising tide of anti-Semitism
maybe some of them will have a better
idea of life
not to mistreat other people a message
that a new generation like Montana
Tucker an influencer on Tick Tock seeks
to carry forward my grandparents both
are Holocaust Survivors we can't talk
about the Holocaust without talking
about anti-Semitism the tour for
Humanity is a mobile classroom designed
to empower people to take action against
hate so where are we right now we're in
the Toronto Holocaust Museum on the
Sherman campus and in just a few months
a state-of-the-art facility for
Holocaust Education will open in Toronto
when a visitor has concluded the tour
the visit you know what are you hoping
that you have now equipped them with we
hope to inspire them through the actions
of the survivors who went through this
terrible trauma and yet came here
rebuilt and then used their voices to
stand up against Injustice Karen
Lieberman Global News Toronto
now to Russia's war in Ukraine there
were fresh rounds of deadly shelling in
eastern Ukraine today several civilian
buildings were hit including two schools
at least eight people were killed
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielenski
calls the situation in the Donetsk
region extreme extremely acute he says
Russian forces aren't just storming
Ukrainian positions they are destroying
towns and Villages the West is trying to
head off a new Russian offensive by
agreeing to send battle tanks though
they won't arrive for some time
Ukraine's ambassador to France says 321
heavy tanks have now been promised
including four from Canada Canada has
sent other military and financial aid as
well but the conflict in Ukraine has
many countries including Canada
reassessing their military strength in
an interview for the West block our
country's top soldiers says the Canadian
military is not ready to tackle major
security challenges our Ottawa bureau
chief Mercedes Stevenson spoke with him
Donna it is no secret that there are
concerns in the military and among
allies about Canada's Personnel shortage
and degenerating military capabilities
this week on the west block we are
sitting down for a candid one-on-one
with Canada's top Soldier chief of the
defense staff General Wayne Air General
Air is blunt in his concern about a
deteriorating Global Security situation
and whether the military is ready for
what's coming down the pipe do you think
that you are ready right now right now
for the challenges that lie ahead no and
that's why it's so important that we
reconstitute our Force get our numbers
back up that we get the capabilities in
place that are relevant for the future
security environment while at the same
time as we as we focus on that future
piece being able to respond today we'll
also chat about whether Canada is at
risk of falling short of meeting its
natal requirements if Russia decided to
expand the war which is always a
discussion I know you're having this
with your colleagues all the time that
they decide to go into somewhere like
Latvia or Lithuania what I'm hearing you
say is that Canada might not be able to
respond at the level that we should be
if that happened is is that accurate so
we spent a lot of time focused on what
our commitments are to Nato uh what
capabilities that uh that we've pledged
to Nato if if that happens and and so
um if we did have to respond
um we would meet those pledges but it
would be a challenge it would be on all
hands on deck event we'll have more
ahead on the show on Sunday morning
Donna okay Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa
thank you ahead of MPS returning to the
House of Commons there are competing
Visions over this country's future
speaking to their respective caucuses
prime minister Justin Trudeau and
opposition leader Pierre Paulie have
offered their perspectives and it feels
a bit like the start of an election
campaign Toria Israeli looks at how the
messages are resonating with Canadians
we're not in an election but
conservative leader Pierre pauliev
already seems to have a campaign slogan
Everything feels broken polyevs spoke to
his caucus painting a bleak picture of
Canada and laying the blame squarely on
the Prime Minister you failed to hold
the scumbag corporations who brought
these drugs to our streets accountable
look around you
crime is Raging out of control in our
streets
our people are desperate that they'll
have to lose their homes on the same day
Trudeau addressed MPS and also
intensified attacks against his main
opponent now there are politicians like
Mr pauliev
who have no real solutions to offer and
who just try to exploit the anger and
concerns that people do have
the liberal vision for the future could
not be more different Trudeau admits
times are tough with fears of a
recession and the Health Care System
under major strain but he insists the
Liberal Party can steer Canada through
all the challenges Canada is broken I
think actually is going to wear thin
with Canadians I think there are things
that Canadians are frustrated about but
as a whole we don't think our country is
broken but this conservative strategist
believes pauliev's message is resonating
he's reflecting the anger anger over
clogged emergency rooms the rising cost
of living and uncertainty about the
future I was not afraid to be sharper
with his language and he probably can
get away with that now but I don't think
when you actually get to the place of
getting to the voters the um the the the
scumbag dirt bag sleaze bags a bag of
tricks language is going to work for the
Liberals the challenge after eight years
in power is presenting a fresh face to
Canadians the conservatives have a fresh
face but the question is whether his
combative style will appeal to swing
voters Donna all right turia Israel and
Ottawa thanks it has been three years
since covid-19 infected Our Lives coming
up what some doctors fear could happen
if the pandemic is declared officially
over
[Music]
the state of emergency has been declared
in Auckland New Zealand torrential rain
and heavy flooding has led to
evacuations some people were forced to
abandon their cars and power has been
cut to thousands about 40 000 Elton John
fans found themselves out on the street
after the flooding led to the
cancellation of his concert just minutes
before it was supposed to start it's
estimated about 15 centimeters of rain
fell within 11 hours well it's a little
hard to believe it's been three years
since the World Health Organization
first published details of a worrying
virus it was eventually named covid-19
and now it is back before a special who
committee that committee is set to
decide if the virus still fits the
definition of a public health emergency
of international concern if not the
pandemic would be declared over but as
Crystal gomancing Reports some doctors
fear that would result in more confusion
and misinformation spreading
the spherical spiky virus and
internationally recognizable image in
2020 the novel coronavirus caused the
world to shut down while claiming lives
at an unheard of rate 36 months later it
may no longer be classified as a public
health emergency of international
concern I will not preempt the advice of
the emergency committee I remain very
concerned by the situation in many
countries and the rising number of does
the most notable increase occurred in
China which ended its zero covet policy
in December of last year
that combined with low vaccination rates
led to a surge in deaths and
hospitalizations
the term pandemic does not refer to
virus severity but the geographical
spread of a virus that people don't have
any immunity to fight declaring a
pandemic is the loudest warning Bell to
the public that the who can ring it's
important that when they do lift that
designation they still communicate that
covet is still here it's not going away
it's going to Wax and Wane it will
likely be called endemic meaning it's
known and circulating
covid-19 has been a magnet for
misinformation and Dr Isaac bogosh fears
the change in terminology will be
distorted what will really be helpful is
if even when that technical designation
is lifted that senior political leaders
and Senior Public Health leaders and
countries around the world still support
measures to protect individuals and to
protect communities public views on
covid-19 are divided it will all come to
light that this is nothing more than a
form of control anywhere I go I wear my
mask yeah people just need to be safe
the head of the who will make the final
call based on the recommendations of the
emergency committee it's not known when
that decision will be made public
Crystal gemancing Global News London
Canada's capital after the Convoy ahead
how those disruptive protests have
changed Ottawa
Ottawa later
a year ago news about the so-called
Freedom Convoy was dominating the
headlines the trucks were allowed to
roll in and occupy the streets near
Parliament Hill for weeks and blockades
were set up at several border crossings
one year later Ottawa has a new police
chief and police are stepping up their
presence in the downtown about 500
people are expected on Parliament Hill
this weekend our chief political
correspondent David Aiken has a look at
what impact the Convoy is still having
on National politics David
well Donna I'm standing on Wellington
Street that's the street that runs right
in front of the parliament buildings and
this street has been closed to most
traffic for security reasons ever since
the freedom Convoy rolled in one year
ago I'm certainly not marking the
anniversary in any way and our Focus now
is on making sure it doesn't happen
again
some federal politicians too never wish
to see such a demonstration again that
it represented the high water mark of a
of a very extreme populist movement that
was frankly disrespectful of other
people's rights disrespectful of
diversity
disrespectful Democratic processes but
to some the protests gave a voice to
angry frustrated Canadians it brought at
least for me and a lot of people around
here hope I know everyone has their own
opinions on it but for us it's about
hope I think the significance is that
the Convoy probably never should have
had to happen but people are frustrated
in this country and they have every
reason to be that anger that frustration
continues to drive political behavior in
many parts of the country I do think if
anybody thinks what happened in the
trucker protest is going away you know
adjust your thinking it's definitely
going to be a feature in the next
federal election campaign because it
tends to work for both the Liberals and
somewhat argue for the opposition as
well Sutcliffe the Ottawa mayor hopes
for a return turn to a more civil kind
of politics I remain optimistic by
nature and and I'm hopeful that we can
that we can avoid a lot of that
nastiness but I am concerned about it
now as for this Street Wellington Street
a lot of people on city council wanted
to return to normal they want to bring
the traffic back but a lot of MPS have
some different ideas they would like to
see the federal government extend its
jurisdiction here expand the security
zone of the Parliamentary Precinct to
better protect Canada's Democratic
institutions Donna all right David Aiken
near Parliament Hill tonight thanks
David
next on our thing what could be the
oldest most complete mummy ever found in
Egypt
[Music]
archaeologists are constantly at work in
Egypt it is a treasure Trove and now
they say they've made another remarkable
Discovery they've uncovered what they
believe is the oldest most complete
mummy ever found
zakara is very important place it
reveals many important treasures and we
announced it today one of these great
Treasures that treasure they say was
found in this tomb a gold leaf covered
mummy sealed inside a sarcophagus that
had not been open for 4 300 years it was
found in a tomb 20 meters underground at
a burial site just south of Cairo
they're not showing it to the public yet
archaeologists have spent years
Excavating the site around the ancient
ruins of Sakara 14 stone statues
possibly even older than the mummy have
also been found
that is global national for this Friday
I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your Canada
is snowy Wascana Park in Regina
Saskatchewan we'd love to see your
Canada please email it to us and thanks
for watching hope to see you tomorrow
for the new reality bye-bye
[Music]